we try really hard to cover a lot
yesterday under trying conditions it was
but we did get there we took this idea
of balloons right and we established at
least the basic result that if we're to
take function right instead of working
out area where they need to roll we can
work out a whole view by now what was
the most affordable result that we end
up with remember the first thing is PI
okay then the integral you're slapping
whatever boundaries you like and then
what you are actually integrating is y
squared DX
okay so you remember together this pie
really belongs with that y squared so
it's just like PI R squared because
these bottoms are any they're solids of
revolution so adding up a whole series
of circles together okay so I think we
arrived there and they're reversion to
us that we didn't really get much
opportunity to do examples apart from
like spheres and all the results already
know so let's look at something we don't
know and see if we can work out how does
this so he's a function let's pick some
boundaries
I'm gonna go from from 0 to 3
one of the advantages of what we live in
chokeboys and then up to 3:00 Sunday
where you like okay now wait used to
talking about the area if we were trying
to work out this area and stay in the
area under X square plus one bounded by
now what are the other three boundaries
there three other boundaries of play
another one the x-axis you could call
this all axis but a better way of saying
even though it seems the same is x
equals 0 and x equals 3
cuz it's not always an axis it could be
x equals 1 and x equals 3 oh whatever
now therefore sort of up if I draw back
those boundaries you another one you'll
hear this volume that are about to get
that about to draw right they will often
refer to it as this area be rotated
around okay so they'll say the area
under x squared plus 1 battered by blah
blah blah is rotated around the x axis
and often on the diagram they'll provide
you you know the direction is going okay
sure
are you ready this way it's for your
cool what's this sound bottom you're
gonna look like when we actually do the
revolution well it is very similar to
the current that we had before but it's
kind of chopped off
but unlike a cone you know the slant
line is not the straight line is its
curved okay so we're going to take that
into account so one way to think about
it is just take the beginning and draw
the circle that comes from that so
but we're looking at Sidon yeah so
there's one circle that comes from this
there's a circle to comes from this
which obviously is much larger so by the
way be careful is probably worth getting
out your ruler and I'm measuring that
distance so that you've got a so that
you get the symmetry so your shape looks
kind of decent okay so here's the other
circle okay so if you're like I'm
looking at it from this angle okay so
that's what I could see in this if you
like at the top right and this is the
bottom so that's why I can't see this
part and how do you get the rest of it
well it's gonna be this curve and you
flip it upside down so can you okay now
the next part it's not necessary really
but it just helps with visualizing
things I'm gonna put a few lines in here
things like this just to make the
curvature of it a little more obvious
visualizing is so important it really
really is valuable so there's the volume
now how do we calculate it every time no
exceptions I do a volume kushman I
always write the formula with no things
put into it very boundaries no functions
if you like that because do you ever I
told you yesterday when doing following
questions there are two common areas
that people make and you know either
remember the actual integration you get
quite good at integration right the
algebraic process usually you forget the
PI or you forget the square okay because
you're focusing too much other stuff so
riding now the formula is the best way
to guarantee you're going to get all the
pieces here cuz if you write the formula
wrong like if you like that it doesn't
even look right okay see something looks
like it's missing and in the same way if
you forget the square you know that's
that's an area obviously right so that's
why
I'll write down the formula first let me
dump that now I'm going to substitute
some actual values in okay so the PI is
out the front one of my boundaries it's
a it's zero to three because I'm going
around the x-axis so I'm interested in
these expound roots right so door three
now y squared in this case is that swear
because that's why yeah we respect that
okay so this is got to expand this guy
and then we could just treat it as a
polynomial and raise the powers divided
by that this is X to the 4 - x squared
and then from this point there's nothing
unusual about it you could treat this
just like any other definite integral
you have to work out okay so this is PI
from this what's that gonna be two
thirds to three
what do we got what's what's 3 to the
power of 5 3 cubed is 27 3 or 4 is 81 so
the next one up is 2043 all on 5 that's
going to be three cubes thank you sir
plus 3 and then I'm going to subtract
all of these will be 0 for the lower
bound yeah okay what's that
I'll do a bit of simplifying before I
get my calculator out 2/3 of 27 is 18
plus 3 that's 21 okay now that's
infraction and I can't really be
bothered what is it come out to anyone
got the calculator there
102 exactly like I said no fractions
anything really that's a fire
that's a fire buddy let's try that again
I was like this doesn't see something
348 okay calculation was fine it was the
reading that was sorry I guess mine
writing so this is uh this is the
integral that I worked out I think the
best way to conclude rather than just
slapping units on there is to have a
second line or you know put off of the
side for you volume is and this is I
don't have any units so it's just units
okay and it's acute great now that's not
too difficult but yesterday I started
talking about the fact that there are
there's more than one kind of volume
right so I'm good to see so taking the
same function right and even taking the
same boundaries so I'm gonna have this
kind of shape here and I've got zero and
that'd be three is there not a volume
that I can make just as easily out of
this okay because here I rotated around
the x-axis right but surely I can rotate
around the other extra I could rotate
around any X as I live right now before
we start doing the mass of it what's the
shape gonna look like how would you
describe the shape okay so you can think
of it to come through and it's kind of
like a ball with a pointy end on the
bottom so it does not gonna sit very
well it's kind of like a half a football
if you cut it in half because it kind of
does come to a shop way the important
thing is you get the symmetry right so
here if I draw the other side
oh sorry I know it's a parabola so it's
actually gonna you don't have a
stationary point yeah so it's gonna come
up turn there and then because I'm going
around this way down so if you like put
on a diagram that kind of our right
the circles are going to form which I'm
gonna add up like that so this Allen is
that ball though it's not that bullish
it's not very useful as a ball because
it's solid to the camp or you know stuff
I know but this is the shape which okay
we can work out what that is but I'm
gonna leave that for now because it's
going to be a different kind of shape
okay so that's why these picked up at a
useful thing right here
I took the area underneath and then I
retained this way right here I've taken
the area above and then I'm rotate now
you tell me a wire I'm actually going to
suggest that this is a more natural way
of taking this volume why would it be
more natural to take what what actual
area results instead of this area here
it's gonna be that's right now because
I'm rotating around the y-axis right
think about this with me remember the DX
it was like that little width there
every little width that I've got okay
I'm not gonna have widths here right
because the circles that I'm getting
they're stacked up on top of each other
like this vertically right so they're
not going to be DX wide instead they're
going to be
dy hi all walls if you like ok whichever
way you do that so this volume I can
calculate it differently it's still
gonna have the PI out the front pi comes
from the circles that I'm getting but
I'm not gonna write a to be I'm not
gonna write a to be even though it's
it's you know in some ways it's just
letters right and you know call them
whatever you like I'm gonna come and see
me just so I distinguish them from and
be always the X batteries right 0 3 ok
but I'm now thinking about a different
axis okay I'm thinking bout rotating in
a different way
so I'm thinking out different boundaries
now in this case good which you simply
get just from substituting these in a
function now before we had 120 X okay
cuz Y squared was like the radius
squared and DX is the width now the
radius is not y squared it comes from
this horizontal thing and horizontal is
X right so it's x squared dy
okay it's just a swath okay the way and
I tend to read it right just like we'd
say oh this is integration with respect
to Y right I also think of it as
rotation with respect to Y okay it's a
different kinda rotate
okay now just like with this question
I'm just gonna write that formula down
and now I'm gonna put some values into
my okay now I think I've Jessi already
told me the actual banners aren't you
sending off one through ten okay now
this is kind of nice for us in this case
x squared actually already appears in
the equation we start again right all I
have to do is rearrange a little bit
right so x squared on its own y -1 yeah
so that's what I'm gonna integrate
and now I've just turned it into a
definite room and off I go okay let's go
and work out with the values up high
what is the intro of y -1 look at you
for you to answer
let's go to youth minus y12 1 to 10 okay
so from here it's pretty standard get PI
outside off now save some time if I
remember this properly I think it's
about but you can go ahead